bonsoir malienne quelles sont les
conséquences de cette élection au niveau
intérieur
bonsoir ses fans et oui le gouvernement
donc récupérer une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale il y aura donc une
certaine cohérence institutionnelle à
nouveau avec un parlement qui ne sera
plus dans une posture de défiance
ouverte envers le pouvoir exécutif
concernant l'opposition qui a présenté
donc des candidats plus de 13 mille
candidats une partie de l'opposition à
présenter des candidats et elle a
remporté 18 % des suffrages
donc un certain nombre de députés de
l'opposition ne pourront siéger à cette
assemblée nationale et exercer leur rôle
de double de comparable de contre
pouvoir au parlement
ces élections permettent donc de sortir
d'une situation de blocage total au
venezuela qui avait cours depuis 2015
date des dernières élections
législatives remportées majoritairement
par l'opposition incarnée par croire
soient noyés d'eau depuis depuis deux
ans principalement qui était dans une
dans un refus total de tout dialogue
avec le pouvoir exécutif et qui avait
comme leitmotiv comme seul leitmotiv de
renverser le gouvernement et la personne
du président élu nicolas maduro
le leader de l'opposition à roanne
brideau appelé au boycott de ces
élections est ce que les résultats lui
donnent raison
il est il est indéniable que la que
l'absence que l'abstention pardon et a
été très importante elle est à hauteur
de 69 % alors l'appel de juan garrido
qui est le leader d'une partie de
l'opposition il faut le préciser a
certainement fonctionner mais ce n'est
peut-être pas le seul paramètre à
prendre en compte pour analyser cette
forte abstention
il y a d'une part la crise sanitaire qui
touche tous les pays et qui n'épargne
pas le venezuela qui a pu jouer dans
cette forte abstention
on a pu le voir d'ailleurs dans des
élections en roumanie des élections
législatives en roumanie hier avec le
même taux d'abstention on a pu le voir
en france en juin avec une forte
abstention lors des municipales
deuxième tour des municipales il y avait
il me semble 59 % d'abstention au
deuxième tour des municipales en france
donc la crise sanitaire peut expliquer
cette forte abstention et au venezuela
elles s'additionnent à une crise
économique extrêmement forte qui touche
la population de manière très brutale la
population en est réduite aujourd'hui à
se chercher au quotidien des solutions
pour le pour lutter pour sa survie pour
l'alimentation pour par exemple les
files sont interminables pour trouver de
l'essence pour se ravitailler en essence
et donc il faut penser aux régions les
plus reculées du venezuela qui ont
peut-être besoin d'une voiture pour se
rendre dans les bureaux de vote et qui
faute d'essence mais n'ont pas pu il y a
évidemment toutes ces crises ont pu
engendrer une crise de confiance qui est
fait que les gens sont un peu lassé
comme vous l'avez dit dans votre sujet
et qui donc qui est peut-être une crise
de confiance politique
en tout cas la crise économique et
et la conséquence est vraiment une
conséquence des sanctions économiques
brutal à me poser au venezuela par les
états unis et leurs alliés on en
reparlera mais
le quotidien des venezuela et des
vénézuéliens et en tout cas marqué par
ce quotidien extrêmement dure et qui est
la principale de leurs préoccupations
avant même de vous pensez à participer
au jeu électoral alors au niveau
international à quoi faut-il s'attendre
alors sans surprise les états unis et
leurs alliés ont
non a reconnu l'élection il avait
annoncé avant même la tenue du scrutin
make pompéo a qualifié les élections de
mascarade électorale l'union européenne
a dit qu'elle ne reconnaîtrait pas les
résultats de toute façon il l'avait
annoncé en avance l'union européenne
avait refusé d'envoyer des observateurs
malgré l'invitation du gouvernement
vénézuélien
il faut rappeler que donc oui les états
unis continueront à soutenir guido et
l'ont annoncé en tout cas
l'administration trump continuera à le
faire on ne sait pas maintenant si c'est
elle qui gardera le pouvoir aux états
unis wang why do il faut le rappeler
quand même on aurait pu participer
librement à ces élections mais il a
refusé d'y participer et il a appelé à
un maintien et à l'amplification des
sanctions économiques contre son propre
pays de la part des états unis
et c'est ce qui c'est on semble prendre
cette route là en tout cas du côté des
puissances occidentales
ces sanctions il faut il faut il faut le
dire comme j'essaye de le dire tout à
l'heure ont un impact humain important
le cep est requis et le centre d'études
en recherche politique et économique qui
est basée à washington a fait une étude
sur l'impact des sanctions et il a
établi qu'elle était à la source de
dizaines de milliers de morts en fait
ils ont le cvr a publié une étude
estimant à 40 mille le nombre de
bénévoles et les acquis sont noirs des
conséquences des sanctions économiques
qui frappe leur pays
voilà du côté de la rue si évidemment ce
n'est pas du tout le même son de cloche
la russie avait envoyé des observateurs
pour contrôler le bon déroulé du scrutin
la rue le ministère des affaires
étrangères a publié un communiqué un peu
plus tôt dans la soirée et a regretté
que les autres pays
européen
et occidentaux n'est pas envoyé
d'observateurs j'aimerais vous lire ici
une partie du communiqué le processus
des élections venezuela a été organisée
de manière plus transparente et
responsable à bien des égards que dans
certains états qui se sont habitués à se
considérer comme des étalons de la
démocratie difficile de ne pas voir ici
une petite pique à l'adresse des états
unis qui viennent de vivre des élections
présidentielles avec c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire un certain cafouillage
merci à meriem laribi journaliste pour
le site web de rt france et spécialiste
de l'amérique latine